bonsoir Monsieur le Maire
bonjour monsieur Roy ça a été ça a été
soudain ça a été extrêmement rapide la
montée des eaux
oui ben durant le week-end là on avait
quand même là vu les prévisions
météorologiques on était à l'affût de
qu'est-ce qui est on nous annonçait avec
quand même une vigie qui avait été
installée nos professionnels à l'interne
aussi Lionel réseau routier on avait on
a des sondes qui sont installés dans les
rivières de Baie-Saint-Paul qui nous
permettent de suivre en temps réel
l'état et le niveau d'eau et tout ça le
bien qu'on avait mis des mesures
préventives ça l'a fait en sorte qu'on a
dû le aujourd'hui déclarer l'état
d'urgence puisque c'est beaucoup plus
important et imposant que prévu je vais
vous parler de vos quartiers isolés de
des ponts et tout ça mais d'abord sur
les deux personnes disparues parce que
ce qui est de plus important les gens se
posent la question ce sont des pompiers
de Saint-Urbain est-ce que c'est pas mal
l'information là qui que vous pouvez
nous confirmer actuellement
en effet c'est les informations qui
aussi le qu'on dispose au moment où on
se parle et il voulait selon ce que vous
en savez il voulait aider des citoyens
en effet
bon triste triste nouvelle revenons à
baisser Saint-Paul il y a des quartiers
qui sont isolés ou presque comme comment
c'est quoi votre stratégie
mais présentement on s'ajuste en
fonction du temps je vous dirais que la
stratégie elle est modifié elle a été
modifiée à plusieurs à plusieurs
reprises durant l'après-midi la
situation évolue de minutes en minutes
il y a certains secteurs ça s'améliore
d'autres ça détériore donc ce qu'on fait
présentement si on vient en aide aux
gens on veut assurer une sécurité à tous
les baies-saint-paul WARS et les dessins
Polois donc ceux et celles qui ce qu'on
demande aux gens c'est d'éviter de se
promener sur le réseau routier on
demande aux gens de rester à la maison
c'est l'endroit pour la majorité des
gens qui sont plus en sécurité et ceux
qui ne sont pas en sécurité à la maison
ce qu'on vous demande c'est de
communiquer avec les services d'urgence
via le 91 et des membres des services
d'urgence vont venir là à votre à votre
votre cours pour vous sortir de votre
milieu de résidence et par la suite on a
des centres qui ont été ouverts
présentement à l'Arena de
Baie-Saint-Paul il y a un centre qui est
mis en place on accueille les gens on
leur revient en aide et on va ouvrir un
autre centre dans les prochaines minutes
ce soir pour qu'on puisse le relocaliser
les gens il y a deux bretelles
actuellement qui sont fermés qui sont
importantes dans la route 138 et la
route 362 donc c'est assez majeur de ce
qu'on parle aujourd'hui la 138 est
coupée en deux
oui la 138 là dans le secteur de la
literie Charlevoix est complètement le
Sillé en deux donc c'est quand même une
route nationale qui traverse tout le
Québec qui s'inquiète la voie d'accès
aussi vers la côte nord et on a en même
temps la route 362 ou on a dû fermer le
pont là qui est tout près au
centre-ville tout près de la caisse
désormais puisque il y avait un risque
en même temps d'emportements du pont au
niveau du pont donc c'est c'est
dangereux et les ingénieurs en structure
nous recommandaient de fermer
l'installation et on prend pas de chance
avec la situation qui empirent
malheureusement vous avez demandé
l'appui de la Sûreté du Québec bien sûr
ne serait-ce que pour les recherches
pour les deux pompiers qui ont été
emportés par les eaux plus au nord
est-ce que les renforts sont arrivés de
la SQ
oui actuellement les différents
partenaires le sont mises à profit on a
eu des grandes suspensations du Québec
il y a des hélicoptères de la sortie du
Québec qui sont sur place on a eu aussi
des discussions avec les Forces armées
canadiennes on a des hélicoptères de
bagadville de la base ou au Saguenay qui
sont sur place la Croix-Rouge canadienne
également pour offrir les soutien dans
les centres de la Coupe assez des
techniciens ambulanciers du Québec ont
mis en place des véhicules ambulanciers
supplémentaires on a des ressources par
le
sinuso-social qui ont été mises à profit
donc il y a vraiment une belle synergie
les gens nous demandent aussi
l'avez-vous besoin d'être sont disposés
à aider les gens sont serrés dans leur
Charlebois et actuellement lorsqu'on
fait c'est qu'on veut vraiment venir en
aide aux gens sécurisé nos citoyens et
par la suite on viendra pour la
reconstruction et la mise en place d'une
collectivité plus normale il y a les
deux pompiers disparus hormis ça ce que
d'autres blessés à votre connaissance
pour l'installer les informations que je
dispose c'est vraiment qu'il y a deux
personnes qui manquent à l'appel et
sinon on parle beaucoup plus de dommages
le matériau là outre les deux personnes
qui malheureusement ne manquent à
laquelle toujours et l'eau potable c'est
un c'est un enjeu également là
oui oui il y a une majeur là cet
après-midi du réseau d'Acadie qui a fait
en sorte de vraiment le baisser de façon
drastique la capacité de pression du
réseau potable du réseau d'acadieu donc
on a réussi dans les dernières minutes à
retrouver à trouver où était la
problématique on est à corriger le tir
et outre un avis d'ébullition de 3
minutes avant de consommer l'eau qui se
met en place sur l'ensemble du réseau
d'Acadie les citoyens citoyennes vont
pouvoir le retrouver le réseau de la
cadure comme ils ont au quotidien est-ce
que sur le terrain ma copilote puis je
vous laisse aller après est-ce que on
vous dit puis on a vu les prévisions
météo la plus belle serait est-ce que ça
s'améliore ou c'est plutôt stable
ce qu'on a comme information c'est que
il y a encore des cellules orageuses qui
sont le territoire de Charlevoix mais
après on devrait l'avoir une baisse des
précipitations le météorologiques de la
pluie après 19 heures
bon Monsieur le Maire on va se reparler
bonne chance pour organiser tout ça
merci beaucoup merci bonne soirée à vous
au revoir
Bruno l'abbé vous êtes copropriétaire du
camping le genévrier à billes sympa je
l'avais bonsoir
racontez-moi un peu donc est-ce que
d'abord la roulotte qu'on voit là qu'on
a vu plusieurs fois percuter ce pont
est-ce que ça venait de votre camping
oui effectivement là c'est la rivière
qui serpente au centre du terrain qui a
débordé sur le camping il y a des
installations qui étaient relativement
proche de la rivière en bordure qui ont
été touchés mais la rivière circule
actuellement le sur une grande partie du
camping donc c'est une des quelques
roulottes qui ont été qui ont été
emportés quelques donc il y en a
plusieurs
ouais
le décompte actuellement on peut pas
vraiment donner on n'a pas accès au
terrain le terrain est encore inondé
pour une grande partie donc on n'est pas
capable de circuler d'aller voir donc on
sait qu'il y a quelques roulottes qui
ont été emportées par le flot des eaux
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu ça
l'histoire comme ça
rivière qui serpente au milieu du
genévrier mais qui draine un bassin dans
les montagnes au nord de Baie-Saint-Paul
qui est une secteur montagneux boisé
donc une rivière qui a quand même des
fluctuations importantes lorsque des
averses des orages importants mais un
épisode comme aujourd'hui jamais Laurent
60 ans d'existence du camping qu'on vit
quand même proche de la rivière nous
depuis longtemps c'est une première on a
déjà vu des crues des eaux mais à ce
niveau là comme on voit sur les images
que vous montrez si jamais arrivé c'est
les images en direct d'ailleurs qu'on a
c'est extrêmement
impressionnant et c'est causé bien sûr
par les pluies on fera le point avec
waldir dans quelques secondes les pluies
importantes il y avait des est-ce que il
y a deux semaines quand ailleurs au
Québec il y a eu des inondations est-ce
que déjà ça menaçait vous ou c'était
correct donc on est du côté nord du
fleuve donc les rivières serpentent du
Nord vers le Sud
les crues des eaux sont toujours un peu
plus tard de notre côté on est toujours
tributaire de la sonde des neiges en
montagne cette rivière-là comme la
rivière du Gouffre qui cette rivière-là
se jette dans la rivière du Gouffre qui
passe au centre ville de Baie-Saint-Paul
c'est deux deux
rivières qui traînent des secteurs
montagneux donc la fonte des neiges fait
toujours un peu plus lentement et un peu
plus tard mais présentement la pluie du
dernier 24 heures on avait eu des bons
orages la semaine dernière le niveau de
la rivière avait déjà monté mais la
pluie des dernières 24 heures coupler
avec la fonte des neiges avec le fait
que le sol en montagne est encore gelé
puis ne peut pas absorber mais ça donne
résultat comme on voit aujourd'hui la
crue s'est faite de façon drastique en
quelques heures très très rapidement la
rivière a gonflé de près de 18 à 20
pieds là à la hauteur du genévrier à
votre connaissance monsieur l'abbé il
n'y a que le matériel et roulottes qui
ont été emporté il y a personne de chez
vous qui a été emporté par les autres
fermé on est le premier mai il y avait
personne de présent on a un secteur
chalet avec quelques clients qui ont été
évacués mais sur le secteur camping il y
avait personne de présente on se on se
réconfort quand on pense aux deux
pompiers qui sont qui sont manquants on
serait conforte en disant que pour
l'instant c'est aussi du matériel qui a
été affecté merci beaucoup de nous avoir
parlé Bruno Labé copropriétaire du
camping le genévrier à Baie-Saint-Paul
bonne chance à tout ça merci
Monsieur au revoir